on the world we know is gone but keeping
our humanity that's a choice
oh is it Dale I beg to differ
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the most brain-dead show on all the
Internet's and what you know it the
Walking Dead is back now I love talking
about zombies in The Walking Dead where
to survive what weapons to use zombie
decompositions
that's gonna leave a mark one thing that
I love about the Walking Dead is that it
does perhaps the best job of exploring
the mental toll and physical realities
of what it would be like to live in this
spider filled world day after day
well reality's all except for the
deafness of the survivors yeah Bobby
Kirk's I'm not letting that one die oh
yeah and the fact that the blood-borne
insects would transmit the disease you
guys really work hard to find out like
scientific reasons for all this stuff
and they're like oh I don't know
mosquitos not too hard great truth hurts
that's Robert Kirkman by the way the
creator himself who I got to interview
and grill about some of the fan
community's theories about the show he
confirmed who have you been most sad to
see died on the show but Tyrese
definitely Tyre easy and the night has
Rick been in a coma this whole time know
some huge things about the show
including some my own theories but I'll
save more on that until the end of this
episode because first I want to focus on
another realization that hit me as I
watched negan bash out someone's eye
with a barbed wire bat the sheer density
of just awful awful depraved sick human
beings Rick in the group encounter on a
regular basis remember these guys are
taking a few hikes through the American
South in the span of less than two years
according to online sources the end of
season five was only about five hundred
fourteen days after the initial outbreak
but in that year and a half they've run
into murderous dictators flesh-eating
cannibals and more roadside criminals
than you can shake a Lucy lass now at
first I thought this was just for
storytelling purposes no we need to have
drama in the story so let's sprinkle in
a fresh helping of ruthless maniacs
every so often to see how the group
responds but then I stopped and realized
something that if the events of The
Walking Dead happened in real life you
see the exact same thing happened this
isn't a fictional system built on false
stakes and apocalypse like this actually
gives a survival advantage to certain
personality types specifically
Psychopaths and the demands of a zombie
apocalypse in particular means that
you'd start to develop a significantly
higher proportion of sociopaths in the
surviving population so what exactly
does that mean and how does it affect
Rick in the pit
well prepare yourself for one eye
popping conclusion first we need to
define our terms because even in
researching for this episode I was
literally pulling my hair out trying to
get it all straight because no one
standard of definition really exists so
more often than not the word psychopathy
is referring to a mental disorder that
causes a person to not feel guilt
Psychopaths tend to be unfeeling and
have a difficult time connecting with
the emotions of others they're arrogant
and manipulative and tend to be huge
risk takers sociopathy from all my
reading is basically the same thing but
with one small difference in general
usage psychopaths are born while
sociopaths are bred nature versus
nurture severe trauma or some sort of
abuse are the most likely culprits of
creating a sociopath someone with
disaffected emotion and great skill and
manipulation however it's worth noting
that both fall under the category of
antisocial personality disorder or a SPD
so got all that well even if you don't I
think this quote from someone who is
actually suffering from SPD will clear
it up for you quotes have almost no
ability to empathize with others and
even at the death of those close to me I
did not feel sorrow instead I knew that
I should be feeling sorrow so I
exhibited the emotions that I knew I
should be feeling this was the training
and treatment that I received so clearly
we're talking about individuals who have
a hard time reading the emotions of
others well also not really caring about
those emotions or those people much in
the first place
now part of the reason we all love
zombie fiction so much is that we assume
it's our chance to be a badass look at
me getting to wield crowbars and
shotguns and spiked bats looting homes
and having all sorts of creative kills
boom headshots
except there's that operative word kill
something most of us overlook is that
zombie still look very human and
psychologically speaking we're
programmed not to kill each other and
that's not even mentioning having to
kill loved ones who are just bitten we
see the situation played out time and
time again in The Walking Dead Darrell
is forced to kill Dale Morgan must kill
his wife Carl steps up to be the one to
put his mother out of her misery so as
you can imagine being able to separate
yourself emotionally from other human
it's gonna be super helpful when your
very survival is dependent on you
stabbing human looking figures through
the brain all the time ie the trait that
literally defines antisocial personality
disorder and that's something the
walking dead nails time and time again
throughout the series we see men who
could be diagnosed with some form of a
SPD in positions of power
negan the head of the Savior's who
manipulates people with his charm uses
fear to keep people in line and makes
killing into a game from issue 114 of
the comic quote negan rules by fear or
by manipulating people into thinking
he's the only thing keeping them alive
they worship Him for him it's all about
ego all signs of a sociopath through and
through and there's Joe the leader of
the claimers why hurt yourself when you
can hurt other people seems to me like
Caesar sure enough all together and then
really finds his place during the
apocalypse and of course you can't
forget the governor a smooth-talking
manipulator you're not prisoners here
you're guests you want to leave as I
said you're free to do so who rules with
an iron fist killing anyone who
threatens him without hesitation
including his own man keep poking the
bear and you're bound to get more then
there are the people who were changed by
the apocalypse not changed in the sense
that they became a zombie but rather the
traumas of the apocalypse changed them
into sociopaths and perhaps no one
exemplifies this better than Gareth head
of terminus a group of literal cannibals
terminus started as a community to help
others who needed it in the aftermath of
the zombies so when a violent road gang
took advantage of their goodwill and
started killing them imprisoning them
and raping them he changed from this
butcher we're here the cattle becoming
murderous becoming distrustful and
manipulating others only to betray them
turning into a sociopath was a survival
advantage for him and his crew so as we
see with Gareth you would think that
communities who don't have a SPD the
ones who look for peaceful solutions and
work toward community minded goals
people like Rick and the Grimes would
get swallowed up by these characters are
do if you're not willing to pull the
trigger first this sociopath is gonna do
it for you we can all live together
there's enough room for all of us
kill them all
oh is that it do the sociopath slowly
weed out everyone else in the zombie
apocalypse until it's just a world of
Meegan's and governors well not
according to the show and not according
to science the sociopathic leaders and
ruthless criminals that we run into
throughout the series all seem to get
themselves picked off one way or the
other by the prolific Grimes gang sure
it isn't always easy but Rick's Rangers
always make it while these supposedly
perfect survival machines end up taking
a biter to the base but why well it
turns out that this post apocalypse is
just another round and good
old-fashioned Darwinian survival of the
fittest and here's what I mean Darwinian
evolution was first based on individual
evolution the best individual survived
fish crow's-feet beasts get optimized
all that jazz but over time evolutionary
biologists have found that that's not
actually the whole story enter group
survival theory and multi-level
selection theory two evolutions of
Darwin's original ideas these are both
really complicated and go into a lot of
genetics and cell biology but at their
core the theories look to explain why
animals in the same species cooperate
with each other shouldn't every
Dalmatian be trying to compete with all
the other Dalmatians for tell nation DNA
domination try saying that one five
times fast
in reality it's now we see instead you
see animals working together in groups
and packs and using altruism to promote
the survival of the species as a whole
well it turns out that when you take
away the basic necessities for human
survival like toilet paper and iPhones
we're still just a species trying to
survive together and not get eaten alive
or go death by shooting guns too close
to our ears and we function by the same
rules as other species especially when
it comes to group survival and
multi-level selection theory humans in a
cooperative group survive better than
lone wolves as long as the groups are
genuinely cooperative like Rick's the
key is that the benefits of a group need
to outweigh the benefits of going it
alone and in the walking dead
loners don't last so when the show
spends all that time slow grinding
through group dynamics it's not just so
that we can see Daryl and Carol have yet
another stunted heart-to-heart in the
moonlight it's because that's the stuff
that's actually keeping every one of
those characters alive so where does
that leave our villains well like I said
group survival Theory only works when
members cooperates and when there's
genuine altruism no who doesn't do
altruism unchecked sociopaths unchecked
Psychopaths people with a SPD they do
narcissism a pathological over
confidence in their own abilities that
drives them away from group survival
theory forget about helping others that
requires empathy and concern for
people's survival something that
sociopaths not only don't feel but
biologically cannot feel personally I
can't stand the character of Carl but he
has one amazing quote in issue 125 of
the comics that summarizes all of this
perfectly whoa
someone is gonna tell you to get used to
this that feeling of being scared and
sad don't listen to them hold on to it
remember it don't let yourself forget it
it's too easy to lose his advice is more
practical than it seems becoming numb to
fear and anxiety about losing people
isn't just a matter of convenience it's
a matter of survival fear drives people
toward group survival theory and without
being able to feel fear you're no longer
the best equipped to survive the egoism
the sociopaths in the series have in
spades still can't make up for the fact
that you can't function in a group in
the long term if you need a perfect
example of it take a look at the
governor's storyline in the comics which
looks a little bit different than it
does in the TV show in the comic it's
not Michonne who ultimately kills him
it's his own army who eventually refuses
to kill more innocent people on his
orders but it also does hold true in the
AMC series in the TV show before
Michonne kills the governor he has to
survive another attempt on his life from
merle a member of his supposed survival
group who turns on him only to side with
his brother so in the end even though it
seems like sociopaths would be the best
fit for survival in The Walking Dead
their lack of empathy and inability to
participate in group survival ultimately
spells their downfall
every time contrary to what the critics
say The Walking Dead does have a message
of hope even if it is buried under main
characters who get their eyes beaten out
or their jugulars torn from their
throats or old lovable doctors who lose
their legs and
chillie their heads I guess in the end I
gotta hand it to Robert Kirkman in the
interview I asked him about this theory
having not done the research yet I was
assuming that it would end that
sociopaths have the best chance of
survival in the apocalypse he told me
this
you know Walking Dead is very much about
how much we care for our family and
loved ones and how we struggle to you
know take care of them protect them how
it affects us when the you know
something bad happens to them and I
think it's that you know the humanity of
that and the core aspect of Walking Dead
is is universal and speaking of that
interview I'm gonna leave you now with
that because it's filled with a bunch of
theory talk that I think you're gonna
really enjoy so in the meantime guys
remember that's just a theory of film
theory actually more accurately a bunch
of TV theories and here's that interview
has Rick been in a coma this whole time
no you heard it here only the ones with
coma there'd be the absolute worst thing
ever like if it seems like it's gonna be
the absolute worst thing ever and it's
not true that seems like a sound theory
but it would be terrible we should shoot
that scene just to mess with people one
of the things that we notice across the
The Walking Dead TV show is that the
zombies have seemed to become more and
more decayed or decomposed as the
seasons have gone on because we
calculated it what did you guys
calculate because they're on the surface
exposed to the elements and because of
the extreme heat of the This American
South they would be fully decayed by
about two months in yeah I mean that's
something that Greg Nicotero and his
team at K&B they sit down between every
season and try and figure out like you
know what's the new advancement that we
can do with a zombie or what's the way
that we can make them look a little
different the idea there is that you
know time is going on and so is there a
period of time that you've kind of had
in your head where that first mega wave
of zombies that we see in kind of season
one dies out or passes on or kind of
returns to the dose like 16 seasons or
so okay but when the audience starts to
move away from the show what have you
been most sad to see you know die off in
the show it's hard to play favorites you
know just of course I do like them all
but Tyrese definitely tired it's hard
with the show cuz they're also connected
to actors and it's like I miss all of
the of course you know you go to press
events and they're not there and all of
a sudden you're like wait where's Steven
yo and why isn't Steven here did you not
come to this one Oh
because that was a mistake and really
liked hanging out with that guy but uh
it's gotten to a point where I'm the guy
on the show that's like hey it wouldn't
be weird if we did a season where we
don't kill anyone it'd be a shock it's
like that's how you shock people now and
you don't kill people can we just not
kill people and then there's always like
well we're a story that needs this but
it's wearing me down is what I'm saying
yeah too much death killing people is
emotionally taxing this way I know it's
the worst I don't know how the serial
killers doing speaking of Tyreese as the
theory goes tell me more there's a lot
of online theories that there are hidden
secrets as to the end of the series in
kind of his death sequence or kind of
the death hallucinations that I'm not
having in his final moments any money
truth or huh I'm not gonna deny anything
beyond 216 years though I don't know if
it necessarily it points to the end but
you know maybe some future event sure
sure
you gotta settle the age-old debate yes
who would notice that I need abates okay
not me okay
dunno that's the question that's you
were here the first not Robert who
wasn't against just to be sure the
debate was Karl vs Michonne versus Daryl
I know the choice is obvious geez all
three at the same time yeah I feel like
that would be at a luau you know they're
gonna have trouble hurting Carl and
Carl's gonna win not because he's the
better fighter but just because the
other two are gonna be at a disadvantage
because of their humanity and they're
gonna underestimate kid but you know
look straight out physical ability and I
gotta give it to Michelle Darrell is
cried more in the show like way more
than was shown as way water but he has a
ranged weapon ranged weapons what he's
he shoots one off she takes it in the
shoulder he's reloading and she cuts his
head I think a lot of people who are
aspiring creators especially who watch
the show would love to kind of know what
it's like when you quote unquote made it
you know did you ever expect to get here
real tough no I don't know I mean you
know the the neuroses that never go away
I'm still insecure still hate everything
that I do I still I still try to make
everything better than then I possibly
can and I'm always disappointed when I
don't reach that level all that creative
torment but then I felt in the beginning
totally still present has it increased
now that it's achieved such a level of
immense popularity that oh I'm gonna let
down
fans or oh I don't want to disappoint
them or incredibly as a sociopath relish
in those moments of like oh man they're
gonna love for this if I start paying
attention to that while I'm trying to
write I'm never gonna get anything done
you know any time I sit down to work I'm
trying to make it good if I try to add
an extra level of pressure because it's
gonna be seen by more people I think it
feel like it's just gonna make the work
bad as a creative person if you're out
there trying to worry about whether or
not the thing you're doing is gonna be
successful or if it's gonna be received
by an audience you're kind of
kneecapping yourself because what you
really should be focused on is you know
does it speak to you that also eat your
vegetables and with that I conclude
therapy with Roberts thank you great
title buds
awesome lots of fun thank you for
proving that he's not in a coma
definitely not in a coma literally the
worst that's terrible
so bad that's terrible